sin límites el tema de esta serie de
charlas yo cuando lo escuché no puedo
evitar sonreír que obviamente hace el
desafío de parte y es que cuando naces
crece en una isla pues los límites las
fronteras los bordes la sensación de
espacios limitados son como parte del
paisaje enmarca en tu vida de forma que
no son necesariamente igual eso creemos
que no son necesariamente iguales en
tierra firme y continental el mar nos
inspira nos abre la imaginación quiere
incluso pensar que nos hace a veces un
poquito más reflexivos introspectivos no
hay uno de los millones de habitantes de
la ciudad de crecí y la habana que no se
haya sentado al menos alguna vez frente
al mar en esos kilómetros de muro del
malecón a preguntarse cuestionarse pues
que hay más allá pero a veces también
nos hiciera el rey en donde la isla se
vuelve no sólo un territorio físico sino
también intelectual emocional empezamos
a hacer este islas a pensar como islas
su nombre preferido virgilio piñera
tenía un hombre parece fenómeno él le
llamaba la circunstancia del
agua por todas partes escribió incluso
un gran poema sobre eso que se llama la
isla en peso el también griego de la
isla cuba donde vengo yo no le fue fácil
pensar diferente dentro de esa isla
intentar saltarse las productoras de los
pensamientos las normas los esquemas
eran años donde pensar diferente tenía
pues un precio muy alto para que soñaba
yo cuando leía esos poemas esos libros
viví en la diestra yo tenía 13 14 años y
creo que creía yo quería lo mismo que
mucha gente quiere saber quería viajar
en conocer el mundo quería vivir de un
trabajo algún día que me permitiera pues
vivir es en realidad asomarme realidad
es que yo sólo veía en películas y que
pensaba que estaban muy muy lejos del
otro lado del mar
y vivir para ayudar a otros a cruzar
también esta frontera yo quería ser
periodista quería contar historias con
palabras con imágenes no me imaginaba
que podía hacer una a ver una forma más
poderosa desde entonces descubrí muy
joven todavía que recuerdo como una
poderosísima puerta de entrada a grandes
historias que eran las organizaciones
internacionales en trabajo humanitario
me fascinaba a todos del mundo en donde
gente tan joven podía tener la
oportunidad de encontrar pues estas
historias tan poderosas desafiar
contextos muy difíciles para llegar a
ellas y ayudar a la gente en el campus
quería ser como ellos que llegaron
primero cuando había pasar un terremoto
o un huracán que se iba de último pues
cuando había situaciones de violencia
desigualdad de pobreza estaba allí para
hacer la diferencia con gente que hacía
la diferencia
pero nunca había conocido a nadie que
hiciera eso allá de mí
el trabajo internacional algo
humanitario para el desarrollo son
profesiones que aún no tienen un cuerpo
un nombre digamos en cuba incluso el
periodismo sea mucha gente me sonreía
cuando era condenado a la sentencia
pero no en cubo inferior y pues
mucha gente pues no se imagina y llega a
pensar que existe realmente una
oportunidad para quienes hemos crecido y
nos hemos formado en esta en esta isla y
en esos contextos de vivir vivir eso
también cuando uno ha crecido en un en
contextos como ese yo vengo de una
familia de mujeres esencialmente de toda
mi madres fue la única que estudió sin
embargo mi abuela pues sostenía todo el
peso económico de la familia desde
siempre mi madre y abuela me enseñaron a
trabajar condicionar ya escuchar la
radio aprendí a leer con periódicos y no
solo con libros para niños periódicos
cubanas obviamente ellos me enseñaron
sobre todo a buscar soluciones formas
creativas a problemas grandes problemas
chiquitos me enseñaron a reconocer
cuando un problema grande con dos
problemas el chiquito enseñaron a pensar
a sentirme a gusto con gente que piensa
diferente
descubrí entonces que para viajar
también estaban hechos el cine el teatro
la música los libros en los cuentos en
los portales cuando vio un apagón de
ocho horas las horas en el malecón los
devoren todo lo que pude leer libros
todos los que encontrar en las librerías
de la habana y los que tenía que forrar
con papel oscuro porque no eran bien
vistos como los de vinieron descubrí que
para contar historias de desigualdad de
pobreza de gente que se reinventa pues
no tenía que salir de la isla si yo
vivía en el paraíso de la gente que
busca alternativas de la gente que busca
soluciones creativas a desafíos que a
veces ni podemos imaginar me empecé a
pactar con circuíto a gente que pensaba
fuera de la caja y que no necesariamente
había estado a mi entrada entre el campo
entre que escribí de sociología entre el
teatro me hizo editora del periódico del
festival de cine de la habana én trabajé
como voluntaria en festivales de teatro
y se campañas para hablar con la gente
sobre cultura de participación
y derechos en cuba me hizo editora de
una revista que llevaba 20 años tratando
de sobrevivir fuera de la caja y sí
salir de la isla pero antes que eso me
metí dentro de ella todo lo que pude me
bebí todo lo que tenía todo lo que
encontré en ella para crecer
ahí obviamente busque o bien entre todos
los sitios que encontré sobre
organizaciones internacionales con los
temas que me apasionaba con todo lo que
había descubierto hice todas las
aplicaciones del mundo para trabajar
para estudiar también comiendo rechazo
porque a veces sin un título de una gran
universidad que resuena en inglés pues a
veces no confiamos en lo que sabemos en
lo que llevábamos a hacer un título de
periodismo de una universidad de juba
imagínense a veces me hacía muchas
preguntas también antes de mostrarlo y
lo digo sin vergüenza de tanto amanecer
con las fronteras en frente a veces te
olvidas de confiar en lo que puedes
hacer hace más de cinco años que trabajo
en contexto comunitario en el trabajo
humanitario he podido crecer en ello he
podido contar las historias de muchísima
gente que también ha vivido o viven
islas de muchísimo tipo con límites ya
veces ni siquiera alcanzamos a imaginar
y me hice un fotógrafo para que ninguna
de esas experiencias
viven y se me escape jamás
esta historia no es una gran historia la
mía no creo que sea no creo que hay
que mucha gente piensa en inglesa con
inglés porque eso le es funcional a
alguien o algo
es armar se desarman cuando lees cuando
busca cuando intercambia cuando te
expones y que vives eliminen cuesta
mucho tengo 32 años y todavía intento
hacer eso todos los días ustedes que
salen pronto es el mundo grande que se
gradúan que se exponen pues este mi
mensaje es vivir sin limites island
fernández-cuesta hay que construirlo
todos los días y a veces cansa entonces
absorban al máximo de cada lugar de cada
momento de cada isla y cuando se lo
hayan sabido todo pues salgan de ella
sin correr y disfruten el viaje aprenden
a reconocer a dialogar con las fronteras
porque saben que a veces viene bien un
ratico de incertidumbre frente al mar
frame de link de que me recuerde quién
eres de dónde vienen por qué te mueve
las cosas que te mueven es lo que puedo
contarles yo que soy hija de isla y que
intentó pues vivir sin límites todo lo
que puedo pero llevando siempre buscando
siempre el agua